BlackRock one of the most powerful
companies in the world just struck a
deal with the president of Ukraine what
is the deal to have BlackRock
reconstruct Ukraine after the war how
Noble right your tax dollars get sent to
Ukraine a good chunk of your money goes
right back into America's military
industrial complex in the form of
weapons and equipment and the other
chunk of your money is going to be sent
to Blackrock to help Ukraine rebuild
neat right the money went out of your
pocket and then right back into the
pockets of America's Elite with barely
any of it actually reaching the
Ukrainian people but I'm sure that
BlackRock doesn't have any arterial
Motors right
explain
[Music]
so you're a black rock CEO Larry Fink
and you spent the last few Decades of
your life building BlackRock into the
world's largest asset manager an
investment company responsible for
around 10 trillion dollars 10 trillion
BlackRock has its tentacles in literally
every aspect of your life and you got
the 10 trillion dollars not by doing
charity work not by donating money to
poor countries out of the kindness of
your heart no you got to the top of the
investment World by being as coldly
calculated what your Investments as
possible because as any good investor
knows investing is simply a game of who
can best take their emotions out of the
equation any emotion and you lose money
which means BlackRock is not in the
charity business when U.S BlackRock
invest money you expect to see a return
and in the case of Ukraine you projected
that you're gonna make Returns on
Ukraine so high that you just can't
foreign
[Music]
with trying to strike a deal with
Ukraine is Ukraine is off limits the
federal government has its hands all
over it you can't just simply fly over
to Ukraine on your own and make a deal
without the US government's blessing you
would be going behind the government's
back you gotta grab any work alongside
the gatekeeper not bribe but luckily
BlackRock already has very deep ties
with the US governments back during the
2008 financial meltdown when the
government had to bail out too big to
fail Banks and corporations who do you
think they call to analyzing clean up
the mess BlackRock BlackRock was awarded
these key government contracts to help
with the Meltdown with no competitive
bidding while being enveloped in secrecy
basically you Larry fink a Wall Street
Elite was hired to bail out other Wall
Street Elites who you just so happen to
be one of the largest shareholders in
clever right you and your friends who
you're invested in created the mess and
got rich off of it the government then
pays you money to clean up the mess and
by cleaning up the mess and belly about
your friends you save your Investments
and no one is the wiser and the same
thing happened during the Great coven
market crash just getting word from the
Federal Reserve and this might be
boosting the markets even more this
afternoon they are talking about the
details of their corporate bond
purchases the FED today going where no
Federal Reserve has gone before uh
scheduled this morning to have begun the
uh corporate bond buying program start
off with this bombshell announcement
from the Federal Reserve Dave not just
buying treasuries and mortgage-backed
securities but also buying corporate
bond ETFs that was a surprise Federal
Reserve and their latest action uh to
get into the bond market in a more
concrete fashion they're working with
BlackRock America's money printer needed
to bail out too big to fail corporations
by buying their corporate bonds but
that's a big complex job who are we
gonna hire to manage all of that
BlackRock BlackRock was hired again to
bail out the same corporations that they
were heavily invested in so as you can
see you Larry Fink are a fine special
wizard a financial wizard at the art of
Bridging the Gap between big finance and
big governments and if you're gonna get
in on this Ukraine Alpha you're gonna
need to apply some of that same Magic
Touch here the Ukraine war is a complex
situation President Biden doesn't have
all the answers he has to rely on
advisors to suggest the best course of
action to take which is why you gotta
get a man on the inside to be one of
those advisors and you have the perfect
man for the job a guy named Eric Von
Nostrand the head of research for
multi-asset strategies and sustainable
Investments at BlackRock sustainable
Investments like Ukraine all you gotta
do is get him on the inside which should
be simple given your connections and
boom in August 2022 Eric Von Nostrand
left BlackRock to become a senior
advisor for the Bonnet Administration on
economic issues related to what do you
know Russia and Ukraine and his task was
simple the government would confide in
him when it comes to questions like how
long should we support the war before we
move on to the next phase what would be
the best way for America to help say
reconstruct Ukraine and confide in him
they did luckily he had the perfect
solution to all their problems a
little-known company named BlackRock
geopolitics can affect the stock market
and if you're into trading penny stocks
and you're tired of missing out on the
next big thing in the stock market then
you gotta check out microcapdaily.com
where you get access to breaking news
and updates on Michael and small cap
companies and in their articles they go
deep on the analysis like really really
deep analyzing super Niche stuff for
each company that would take you hours
to find on your own it's a penny stock
Trader's dream come true they got the
experienced Financial analysts they got
their relationships and Connections in
the industry and the best part is that
microcap daily is a 100 free newsletter
that you should sign up for right now
with the link below don't let the big
players have all the fun level the
playing field by signing up for their
100 free newsletter right now with the
link below this not Financial advice
please always do your own due diligence
and consult with your financial advisor
and never invest in any stock mention on
microcap daily unless you can't afford
to lose your entire investment thanks to
microcraft daily for sponsoring this
video
[Music]
even if the war in Ukraine comes to an
end in the next few months it's not all
sunshine and rainbows for Ukraine from
there because once the war ends it's not
like Ukraine could just immediately go
back to normal again no Ukraine has
taken a lot of damage which means
Ukraine will have a lot of rebuilding to
do rebuilding that's gonna cost a very
pretty penny in September 2022 after a
counter offensive by Ukraine Russia
ramped up attacks specifically aimed at
Ukraine's population and critical
infrastructure how much was damaged in
total is still hard to determine but
estimates say up to 40 of all housing
and half of all of Ukraine's energy
infrastructure has been completely
destroyed which means as of right now it
will cost you crane between 100 and 750
billion dollars to rebuild the country
and its economy if the war ended today
however if the war lasts just a few more
months or years rebuilding Ukraine will
cost upwards of a trillion dollars or
more a trillion dollars that UK
certainly does not have in fact not even
America has a trillion dollars in
reserves for an emergency like this so
if America doesn't have a trillion
dollars there is no way that Ukraine
will ever be able to get back on his
feet alone on top of that one trillion
dollars Ukraine still has a bunch of
debt they have not paid off 54 billion
to be exact to which they've already
paid 7.3 billion dollars in debt
repayments in 2022 alone and who do they
owe this money to why the IMF will Bank
the European Investment Bank and Western
Banks so the question remains how on
Earth is Ukraine going to be able to
afford upwards of a trillion dollars in
repairs and all the debt they have the
answer BlackRock today's video sponsor I
mean the company that's going to rebuild
Ukraine all you gotta do president
zielinski is sign the dotted line right
here and BlackRock will take care of all
your worries just think of how much of a
hero you'll be after you've not only won
the war but when you've got your economy
back up and running people are really
going to be kissing your feet after that
and in September 2022 just literally one
month after you got your man on the
inside of the Biden Administration you
finally got such a meeting
foreign
[Music]
2022 BlackRock finally got their meeting
with President zielinski the agenda
quote how to revive the country's
shattered economy by attracting public
and private investment End quotes the
two of you talked about how Black Rock
could provide quote pro bono advice to
the Ukrainian government End quotes to
set up a reconstruction fund after the
meeting zelinski said in a statement
quote we've shown that we know how to
win on the battlefield another important
task for us is to achieve victories in
the economy as well and to be an
attractive country for investors End
quotes an attractive country for
investors there now zelinski is speaking
America's language this is great
progress for you but giant deals like
this are never closed in the first
meeting it's a long sales process you
gotta wine dine the prospect you gotta
give them some Value First show them
your worth first so that's exactly what
you did it would take another two months
after that first meeting for something
to come into fruition in November 2022
Ukrainian BlackRock signed a memorandum
of understanding for BlackRock to be the
one to coordinate investment in
rebuilding Ukraine translated from
Newspeak BlackRock was now approved to
be the one that helps Ukraine raise a
bunch of money for the Reconstruction of
Ukraine from both public and private
investors which means once the war is
finally over the floodgates to Ukraine
for the West would be blown right open
the US government can start giving even
more money to Ukraine in the name of
reconstruction U.S construction
companies can move in to start
rebuilding all the critical
infrastructure and housing other U.S
corporations like maybe oil and gas
companies can start moving in to do
business while American bankers and
financiers can start swooping up large
swaths of the Ukrainian economy at fire
sale prices while giving them more loans
basically once the war is over Ukraine
will simply turn into another asset on
the West's ballot sheets it is
how do we know this is what the American
oligarchy is up to it's because almost
this exact scenario has played out
before a country poses a threat to
American interests so America ravages it
with war and once the war is over and
the country is left in Ruins that's when
America sends in one of its corporate
Giants to help reconstruct and plunder
the country except the last time this
happened instead of Ukraine it was a
little-known country named Iraq and the
corporation America sent in that time to
do their bidding why it was none other
than Vice President Dick Cheney's very
own company Halliburton Halliburton is
accused of hundreds of millions of
dollars in improper charges Pentagon
Auditors have found potential
overcharges of 61 million dollars now
the numbers are apparently even larger
than previously thought halliburton's
unreasonable and unsupported bills
exceed one billion dollars several
government agencies are currently
investigating if Halliburton overcharged
for work already completed in Iraq
Iraqis are looking to rebuild every
sector of their economy it is reportedly
not a coincident that Vice President
Dick Cheney's old company got a huge
contract to help rebuild Iraq
reconstruction effort here in Iraq is
expected to cost the U.S taxpayers more
than 18 billion dollars before the end
but some unscrupulous American
businessmen have seen this as their
ticket to get rich quick feeding the
troops the Pentagon has found some
serious problems with halliburton's work
on that contract as well Pentagon
Auditors found that a Halliburton
contract to provide food and housing for
American troops had a staggering 1.8
billion dollars in unsupported costs
there's nothing but the money
there's no duty honor country
among anyone at Halliburton KBR and so
it's time for the United States to start
thinking of Iraq as a business
opportunity
we're gonna expose all of it in part two
so make sure you subscribe
what's happening right now with Ukraine
BlackRock and the American oligarchy is
nothing new this is how America has went
about colonizing the world since the end
of World War II you enslave a country in
debt if you don't succeed you send in
the military and once you do have the
country enslaved American corporations
are then free to go in and exploit that
slave labor and after years of
researching these videos I realized that
this is a secret that those in power
have tried very hard to keep on the Reps
Financial slave labor is the key to
everything the most powerful people in
organizations in the world got to where
they're at by mastering this game of
financial slavery and if you want to
amass money in power you too have the
mass of the game of financial slavery
that's why when I realize all this I
knew I had to share it with you guys so
I put all my findings into my greatest
body of work yets Financial slavery
masterclass 20 plus lessons all narrated
by me in the same documentary style
format you've come to love all centered
around teaching you the secret and how
you can use it to get more money and
power and people have been loving it
watch the first lesson of the method the
class for free right now with the link
below and once you buy you can also get
around a hundred dollars for every
person you refer to the masterclass plus
step-by-step instructions on how to post
Tech talk clips of our videos to go
viral and get more sales click the link
below to join now
[Music]
thank you
now